y la tabla muestra valores seleccionados
de la función continua efe aquí los
tenemos podemos usar el teorema del
valor intermedio para decir que la
ecuación f x igual a 0 tiene una
solución donde 4 es menor o igual a x
que a su vez es menor o igual a 6 de ser
así
escribe una justificación los invito a
que pausa en el vídeo y piensen un poco
en esto por su cuenta antes de
resolverlo juntos
primero vamos a visualizar lo que está
ocurriendo y tratemos de visualizar el
teorema del valor intermedio aquí
tenemos el eje y este es el eje x ahora
aquí nos han dado algunos puntos sabemos
que cuando x es igual a 0
fx es igual a 0 tenemos este punto
cuando x es igual a 2
jeff o fx recuerden que es igual a fx es
igual a menos 2 entonces aquí tenemos
menos dos y cuando x es igual a 4 vamos
a ver
34 fx es igual a 3 123 haré la escala lo
mejor que pueda para que se vea todo y
cuando x es igual a 6 f x es igual a 7
entonces 3 456
ahí está por otro lado también nos dicen
que la función es continua así que una
forma intuitiva de pensar en la
continuidad es conectando todos los
puntos sin levantar el lápiz supongamos
que la función se ve así podría ser que
tenga más fluctuaciones pero digamos que
así se ve nuestra efe ahora el teorema
del valor intermedio nos dice que
debemos elegir un intervalo cerrado aquí
estamos eligiendo el intervalo cerrado
de 4 a 6 vamos a ver aquí tenemos 1 2 3
4 5 y 6
estamos analizando este intervalo
cerrado y el teorema del valor
intermedio también nos dice que si la
función es continua en ese intervalo
cerrado la función f
tomara todos los valores / efe de 4 que
en este caso es igual a 3 y efe de 6 que
en este caso es igual a 7 entonces
efe de 6 es igual a 7
si alguien pensó hoy habrá una solución
para f x 5 que se encuentra dentro del
intervalo c en este intervalo para
alguna equis tendremos que fx es igual a
5 pero aquí no nos preguntan por una f x
que sea igual a algo entre esos dos
valores nos preguntan por fx 000 no se
encuentra / efe de 4 y f de 6 así que no
podemos hacer uso del teorema del valor
intermedio y si quisiéramos escribirlo
podríamos decir que es continua continua
pero 0 no se encuentra entre f de 4 y f
de 6 por lo que el teorema del valor
intermedio el teorema del valor
intermedio no aplica
ahora hagamos el segundo aquí nos dice
podemos usar el teorema del valor
intermedio para decir que hay un valor
ce tal que fcc sea igual a 0 y 2 sea
menor o igual a c que a su vez es menor
o igual a 4 de ser así escribe una
justificación entonces aquí nos dicen
que si f es continua lo escribiré nos
dicen que es continuo podríamos
especificar el intervalo pero en general
nos dicen que es continua y después
podemos analizar en qué valor se
encuentra la función en los límites del
intervalo vamos a ver nuestro intervalo
va de 2 a 4 así que nos interesa esta
parte y sabemos que f de 2 es igual a
menos 2 porque lo tenemos en la tabla y
cuál es el valor de f de 4 bueno
efe de 4 es igual a 3 entonces 0 está /
efe de 2 y f de 4 y de hecho aquí lo
podemos ver visualmente
y forma de dibujar la línea sin levantar
el lápiz entre este punto y este sin
cruzar por el eje x es decir sin tener
un punto en donde la función es igual a
cero entonces podemos decir de acuerdo
al teorema del valor intermedio hay un
valor ce tal que fcc es igual a 0 y 2 es
menor o igual a c que a su vez es menor
o igual a 4 lo único que estamos
diciendo es que aquí debe de existir un
valor c que se encuentre justo ahí entre
2 y 4 donde fcc es igual a 0 a veces
esto puede parecer confuso pero
finalmente es algo muy intuitivo si
tenemos que pasar de este punto a este
sin levantar la pluma tenemos que cruzar
por lo menos una vez por todos los
valores que existen entre f de 2 y f de
4 hemos terminado pero nos vemos en otro
vídeo